- I've actually met Secret
Service people before
and they're pretty intimidating people,
so, I'm a little scared.
- I did pretty well at my SATs,
so, I think I'll do pretty well in this.
- I consider myself a smart person.
Although, I did average
on ACTs in high school.
- I enjoy any game that,
like, challenges me mentally.
So, you know, crossword puzzles, riddles,
word puzzles, things of that nature.
- When I was in the second
grade, I took an IQ test
and I actually tested in a genius level.
So, that's kind of...
I'm not being braggy, that's
just the fact of matter.
- They're comparing Jake and Megan
but we don't have any,
we don't have any comparison
directly to Jake or Megan.
So, for me there's insufficient
information to decide.
Awesome.
- Oh, dear.
I'm cut in a loop.
- That's true.
- That is true.
- Mark and Rob have a direct comparison
and that's through Jake.
So, saying that Mark completed
more investigations than Rob is true.
- True.
- Awesome.
- It's the same question but reversed,
I feel like this is a trick.
- The statement beforehand
is the direct opposite.
And since we said that that was true,
Mark completing fewer investigations,
the opposite is true, so that is false.
- That's false.
- Yeah.
It's false.
- Nailing it.
- Yes.
- Amy is a secret service special agent.
That means that Eric is
a secret service agent.
- True.
- Because Eric and Amy
have the same position
and Amy is a secret service special agent.
- Damn right.
- Jim could be a secret
service special agent.
Actually, it's insufficient
information to decide.
Because there could be
more people in the office.
- Jim and Amy and Eric all
work in the same office
but there can only be two
secret service agents.
We already established that
Eric and Amy are the agents,
so Jim is not.
- True.
- What?
- Isn't that a technicality?
- Yeah.
- That would be false, right?
Or wait...
- I think it would be insufficient
information to decide.
Because it still doesn't establish...
- Because we don't know if Jim's
a secret service special agent.
- Yeah, and we don't know if Eric
works at Jim and Amy's office.
- Insufficient information to decide.
Uh, it's wrong.
The more I thought about
it, the more confused I got.
It was just like, I was
thinking about the question
and all the lines and then just like,
I had to step back and
then I would get the answer.
- I like to think I have a logical brain.
I know that I'm a visual person
and so, seeing things written out
is not the ideal form for
me to do problem solving.
- No offence to the quiz maker
but I fell that they were easy.
It's just that, the
syntax of every statement
could lend itself to cause confusion.
- I am always bad with decision making.
I constantly weigh pros and cons,
I go back and forth.
So, actually, I should have known
I would have done bad on this test.
So, I guess, I don't
know myself well either.
- They're able to make these decisions
at a pretty quick pace and, you know,
often at times probably
their life is on the line.
And so, for someone to have
these kind of problems
going on in their head
while they're also in
a stressful situation,
is pretty impressive.
- They're about to give us, like,
the official certificate or medal
and they're like, but wait,
now you step in front of a bullet
and we run away crying.